we are gonna get through this thing
bring it through this thing together
Canada's homegrown celebrities are
calling on all of us
to plank the curve hello there's a Seth
Rogen I'm in my bunker where I've
emptied out all my hoarded toilet paper
in Purell to record this message hi
everyone you may know me from Pocky the
Olympics in this uniform but you may not
know that I also wear this one has a
doctor in training in my final year of
med school now you definitely don't want
to be seeing me in the hospital so
practice social distancing and stay that
being home please stay home or if you're
Ryan Reynolds please stay in a palatial
looking barn like structure
stay inside everybody just stay inside
do what I do and hang out in your
basement your house also probably very
cool Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
kicked off the social media challenge
urging Canadians to stop the spread of
kovat 19 by staying home if we all step
up and do the right thing we will get
through this together so help me spread
the word and let's plank the curve in
classic Ryan Reynolds fashion the actor
acknowledged his nomination and the real
superheroes of this global pandemic I
think in times of crisis I think we all
know that it's it's the it's the
celebrities that we count on most
they're the ones who are gonna get us
through this right after healthcare
workers of course first responders
people working essential services
ping-pong players mannequins the PM's
other nominee Canadian crooner Michael
Buble was actually ahead of the curve
posting this Instagram video days prior
these are extraordinary times and they
call for extraordinary measures we need
to support our heroes and healthcare and
empower our leaders who will be making
tough decisions in order to keep our
country safe please do your part and
stay home
you